en la can academy existen varios vídeos
sobre las técnicas de cómo factorizar
cuadráticas pero lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo es obtener algo de práctica
sobre cuál es la técnica adecuada para
factorizar una cuadrática así que voy a
escribir un montón de cuadráticas y te
encargo que pausa el vídeo ip así puedes
factorizar la ecuación que escriban
antes de que la factory se contigo bien
así que veamos el primer ejemplo va a
ser 6x cuadradas + 3x entonces pausa el
vídeo e inténtalo bueno tal vez lo
primero que te salte la vista es que
ambos términos tienen un factor común o
ambos son divisibles entre 36 es
división entre 3 y también 3 y además
ambos son divisibles por equis entonces
podemos factorizar un 3 x
3x que va a multiplicar y tengo 6x
cuadrada entre 3x bueno esos 2x y
después tengo 3x entre 3 x lo cual es 1
y esto es todo lo que podemos factorizar
puedes verificar que estas dos
expresiones son iguales entre sí y se
distribuye este 3x multiplicando 3x por
2x es 6x cuadrada y 3x por 1 es 3x y
regresamos a lo que teníamos así que en
este caso hemos acabado tenemos todo lo
que se podía factorizar es decir lo
único que teníamos que hacer en este
ejercicio era encontrar un factor común
pero como veremos en futuros ejemplos
esta misma idea es un buen primer paso
que nos ayudará a factorizar encontrar
un factor común y si tenemos ese factor
común nunca está de más factorizar lo
así que bueno qué te parece si hacemos
otro ejemplo más digamos ahora que tengo
la siguiente 4
la cuadrática 4x cuadrada menos 4 x
menos 48 de nuevo pausa e intenta
factorizar la lo más que puedas ok
lo primero que seguramente viste es que
hay un factor común entre todos estos
términos
todos son divisibles entre 44 es
divisible entre 4 menos 4 también y 48
también así que vamos a factorizar el
primero un 4 y me quedarían 4 que va a
multiplicar a amd tengo x cuadrada menos
x menos 12 48 entre 42 lo único que hice
fue dividir todo entre 4 y los factores
e incluso puedes distribuir el 4 y ver
que en efecto regresas a la ecuación
original ahora ahmed y acabamos bueno no
ya que el factor que está dentro del
paréntesis éste se puede seguir factor
izando y como hacemos eso bueno por aquí
la clave es que si tenemos un
como coeficiente del término de segundo
grado escrito en su forma estándar ya
sabes la forma estándar es cuando
tenemos el término de segundo grado
después el de primer grado y al final el
término de grado cero o el término
constante y si tenemos un 1 como
coeficiente del término de segundo grado
entonces decimos que dos números su suma
es igual al coeficiente del término de
primer grado es decir del término x que
en este caso es menos uno buscó dos
números que sumados me den menos uno y
bueno recuerda que aquí tenemos un uno
implícito menos x es lo mismo que menos
1 x entonces buscó dos números cuya suma
se iguala menos uno más ven es igual a
menos uno y quiero que esos mismos
números tengan un producto de 12 esta es
una técnica que hemos visto en varios
vídeos y la clave es que aquí tal vez
podamos usarla entonces a por ven tiene
que ser igual a menos 12
y bueno hay algunas cosas importantes
por aquí por ejemplo tengo dos números
cuyo producto es negativo entonces eso
nos dice que deben de tener signos
diferentes uno va a ser positivo y el
otro negativo porque si tuvieran el
mismo signo entonces el producto sería
positivo así que pensemos en los
factores de 12 y especialmente piensen
en las combinaciones de números con
signos distintos así que puedes pensar
en menos 1 y 12 y bueno claro también
tenemos 1 y menos 12 pero menos 112 es
11 y en el otro caso menos 12 más unos
menos 11 nos suman menos 1 así que estos
dos no nos funcionan como queremos
depp después tengo el 2 y 6 se observa
menos 26 es 4 y menos 6 más dos es menos
4 así que tampoco sirven y también tengo
el 3 el 4 menos 34 es 10
- 43 es menos 1 y entonces si sirven
porque el producto de ambos claramente
nos da menos 12 y la suma es de menos 1
entonces puedo escribir lo que está
adentro del paréntesis obtenemos un 4
que multiplica y podemos factorizar esto
que está dentro del paréntesis como dos
binomios el primero va a ser x 3 y el
otro va a ser x 4 y entonces hemos
acabado muy bien ahora si esto te parece
el 'team y dante te encargo que veas los
vídeos sobre introducción a la
factorización de polinomios ojo la clave
insisto es reconocer simplemente qué
método vamos a utilizar así que una vez
más primero intenta encontrar un factor
común que fue lo que hemos hecho en
ambos ejercicios y en este ejercicio en
particular si tenemos un coeficiente de
1 en el término de segundo grado cuando
estamos en una forma estándar bueno pues
simplemente lo que vamos a hacer es
buscar 2
números cuya suma sea el coeficiente del
término de primer grado y su producto
sea el término constante en este caso
fueron tres y menos cuatro y por lo
tanto los factores amos de esta forma
ahora qué te parece si hacemos otro
ejemplo más uno más
vamos a seguir practicando y como
siempre pausa el vídeo y ver si puedes
encontrar la solución tengo 3 x cuadrada
más 30 más 75 y quiero factorizar lo
bueno suponiendo que ya lo intentaste
vamos a hacerlo juntos y primero observa
que todos los términos son divisibles
entre 3 eso es importante entonces
nuestro factor común va a ser el 3 en
este caso y nos quedarían 3 que
multiplican a x cuadra adam + ops espera
espera aquí falta una equis déjame
ponerla de hecho te pido una disculpa es
más pausas de nuevo el vídeo e intentar
resolverlo con esta modificación
el ejercicio correcto bien de nuevo lo
primero es factorizar este 3
entonces me quedarían 3 que multiplican
a x cuadrada más 10 x más 25 y ahora
podemos utilizar la misma técnica que
utilizamos hace rato tenemos un
coeficiente de 1 al lado de la x
cuadrada y como estamos en una forma
estándar entonces necesitamos dos
números que sumen 10 a más bs 10 y que
su producto nos de 25 a por b igual a 25
y esto realmente funciona porque si
piensas en los factores de 25 entonces
vas a decir ok
necesitamos dos números positivos porque
el producto es positivo así que tenemos
125 pero estos no suman 10 y 5 y 5 y
esto sí funcionan porque cinco más cinco
es 10 y 5 por 5 es 25 entonces si usamos
la misma técnica de hace rato tendríamos
tres
que multiplican a x 5 que a su vez
multiplica a x 5 y lo podemos ver como 3
que multiplica a x + 5 elevado al
cuadrado y bueno es que seguramente
algunos de ustedes inmediatamente me van
a decir que no forzosamente tengo que
hacer la misma técnica ya que aquí puedo
inmediatamente reconocer a este trinomio
como un cuadrado perfecto porque tengo
un cuadrado justo aquí y esto es un buen
síntoma tal vez sea bueno que explores
la posibilidad de un cuadrado perfecto
ya que si tenemos a un número elevado al
cuadrado en el término constante y este
de aquí es el doble de la raíz cuadrada
del término constante entonces parece
ser un buen signo de que estamos
trabajando con un cuadrado perfecto pero
de cualquier manera se reconoce es esto
como un cuadrado perfecto o si usas la
técnica que usamos en el segundo
problema en cualquier caso tenemos que
obtener la respuesta correcta